CEO’s have a reputation of being douchebags.
They mistreat their employees, exploit every
tax loophole known to mankind, and they aren’t
scared to put profits before ethics. Basically
every single well known founder has this reputation
including Jeff Bezos, Bill Gates, and Mark
Zucerkberg. Even the most cherished of the
bunch like Elon Musk display many of these
characteristics. I mean 80 to 100 hour weeks
are basically the definition of Tesla and
SpaceX’s work cultures. Many have argued
that though these CEOs have produced tremendous
results, it wasn’t without sacrificing their
humanity. And it often seems like such results
are simply not possible without being a brutal
businessman. But in reality, hundreds of CEO’s
defy this notion with one of the most notable
ones being Southwest CEO Gary C Kelly. In
2021, Gary ranked number 4 on Glassdoor’s
employee choice list with an approval rating
of 98%. Gary hasn’t dropped the ball on
investors either. Since he took over, Southwest
stock has quadrupled at the peak. And let’s
keep in mind, this isn’t a tech company,
it’s an airline company. So, here’s how
Gary stayed on the good side of his employees
while growing Southwest in one of the most
cutthroat and low profit industries in the
world. Taking a look back, Gary joined Southwest
way back in 1986 as a modest controller, not
to be confused with flight controller. By
trade, Gary was an accountant who graduated
from the University of Texas at Austin. Before
joining Southwest, Gary had actually been
working at an auditing company called Arthur
Young & Co. So, becoming a controller at Southwest
was right up his alley. At the time, Southwest
was a rookie in the airline business who was
simply trying to get ahead. The company had
just gone public a few years ago, and each
share of the company was worth less than a
dollar in comparison to today’s prices.
Given the small-scale nature of Southwest,
it wasn’t too difficult for Gary to work
himself up to CFO by 1989, and this is where
he would spend the majority of his early career.
It wasn’t until 2001 that Gary was promoted
to Executive Vice President, but his next
promotion came rather quickly in 2004 to CEO.
Since he became CEO, he’s embraced a couple
of key fundamental values that have cemented
Southwest in the hearts of its employees and
customers starting with a culture of appreciation.
In large companies that employ tens of thousands
of employees, the individual impact of each
employee is often lost. Every employee is
simply a cog in the larger machine and it
often feels like they’re dispensable/replaceable.
But Gary has made sure to emphasize that this
is not the case. And I don’t mean just verbally
thanking employees, Gary has backed up his
words with clear action. Throughout Southwest’s
entire history, they have never laid off a
single employee, not after 9/11, not during
the financial crisis, and not even during
the pandemic. This doesn’t mean that Southwest
just flew through these crises though. In
fact, they were extremely challenging, and
Southwest had to enact several cost cutting
measures. However, layoffs and pay cuts to
regular employees were always a last resort.
I mean just take a look at how Gary handled
the pandemic. When the pandemic rolled around,
it was clear that Southwest had to make massive
reductions in cost given that air travel demand
literally went to 0 overnight. Instead of
laying off employees though, Gary targeted
the other side of the spectrum, employees
that were over 55 and approaching retirement.
Gary offered these pilots over the age of
55 2/3s of their salaries for 5 years or until
they were 65 for simply choosing early retirement.
On top of this extremely generous compensation
plan, Gary also offered up to 5 years of company
provided health insurance. Meanwhile, employees
who were under 55, but had over 10 years of
experience with Southwest were offered 1 year
of salary and 1 year of company paid health
insurance. Given how lucrative this offer
was, 17,000 employees or 28% of their workforce
took the buyout which was quite close to Gary’s
30% target. I think you’d agree that this
was literally the most generous way Southwest
could’ve reduced their workforce. On top
of giving employees a great send off, Gary
and all the executives took a paycut through
the end of 2021. Gary’s salary was cut to
$0 while the other executives' salaries were
slashed 20%. Gary also needed regular employees
to take a pay cut as well, but he didn’t
want to impose it. So, he promised that employees
who took a 10% pay cut would have zero risk
of being furloughed in 2021, and that their
pay would be restored to normal starting in
2022. Throughout the entire crisis, there
was no force or imposing. The approach was
always, how do we get through this as a team.
Maybe older employees can take early retirement,
executives can take a larger pay cut, and
employees can take a smaller pay cut if they
can afford it. Southwest has approached every
crisis with this same team-like approach which
has made the community extremely strong. And
that brings us to Gary’s second strategy
which is breaking down the executive barrier.
As companies grow larger, they often have
a tendency to become bureaucratic, and the
key reason for this is little to no decision
making power for everyday employees. At Southwest,
however, the decision making process is completely
decentralized. As we saw with the pandemic,
it was up to the employees if they wanted
to take a 10% pay cut and avoid a furlough
or if they wanted to keep their full salary
and deal with the risk of a potential furlough.
This decentralization stretches much further
than just allowing employees to choose their
own future though. Employees often make significant
decisions for the entire company itself. A
great example was when Southwest was developing
a new uniform for their employees. Pilot and
flight attendant uniforms are extremely important
as this is what customers see on a daily basis,
and it’s essentially the branding of the
entire company. Given the weight of this redesign,
you would think that Southwest would hire
top tier branding specialists to guide the
process, but Gary had something else in mind.
Gary opened up the redesign opportunity to
all Southwest employees. Every employee who
was interested could provide suggestions for
the new uniform and the employees with best
best suggestions were assembled into a sort
of review team. Every two weeks, this team
would meet up and guide the redesign process.
Similarly, a significant amount of decision
making power is given to low level managers
and employees. Gary believes that these individuals
are the ones that have the best understanding
of the work they do, and that they can make
way better decisions than some executive that
spends their entire day in the office. All
of this is based on Gary’s core idea that
employee satisfaction trumps everything even
including customer satisfaction. The truth
is customer satisfaction is directly linked
to employee satisfaction, so if you keep your
employees happy, customer satisfaction will
follow. This doesn’t mean that Gary doesn’t
care about customers though. If anything,
he cares about each individual customer just
as much as he cares about each individual
employee. If you’ve ever taken a Southwest
flight, you might’ve noticed that they don’t
have business or first class, they only have
economy. Originally, this was because Southwest
was a budget airline and premium flyers weren’t
interested in the company. But today, Southwest
actively chooses against adding first and
business classes. Now, Southwest does offer
something called business select, but this
doesn’t actually get you a better seat or
service. Business select simply allows you
to move up the boarding list and it gives
you some additional member rewards. However,
you’ll be sitting in the same seat and receiving
the same service as someone with an economy
ticket. By opting for no first and business
classes, Gary has been able to prevent an
executive barrier from forming amongst customers
and service. It’s no secret that most airlines
make the majority of their profit from business
and first class flyers thanks to how much
margin is built into those services. However,
this of course creates a large discrepancy
in how customers are treated which goes against
Southwest’s core principle of valuing each
customer equally. Customers who fly Southwest
generally love this aspect. Flight attendants
aren’t prioritizing business and first class
members, and economy customers are the center
of attention. Now, I’m not saying that it’s
wrong to prioritize business and first class
customers given that they’re paying way
more. However, by simply sticking to economy
customers, Southwest is able to provide an
extremely consistent and reliable experience
to all customers. And speaking of happy customers,
we have Gary’s third strategy which is not
nickeling and diming customers or employees.
Ever since 9/11 and especially after the 2008
financial crisis, more and more american airlines
have been charging additional fees on top
of the ticket price for checked bags. And
as more airlines adopt this strategy, it becomes
harder to compete against them because they’re
able to advertise cheaper starting prices.
But the truth is, these cheaper prices are
deceptively low considering that most people
are going to need to check in some luggage.
Southwest has avoided this by simply allowing
all customers to check in two bags for no
additional cost. This has actually become
one of Southwest’s most famous marketing
slogans and is an integral part of the brand
today. Unfortunately, Southwest can’t actually
offer this service for free as it costs money
to transport luggage, and this leads to Southwest's
starting prices to generally be a bit higher
than competitors. But Southwest customers
can be confident that the ticket price is
all they’ll have to pay. There aren’t
any hidden or additional fees that they find
out about when they arrive at the airport.
This policy also extends to other parts of
Southwest’s business. For example, they
don’t charge any change fees or cancellation
fees. If you want to switch from one ticket
to another, you’ll only have to pay the
disparity in ticket price if there is one.
By not nickeling and diming customers, Gary
has been able to largely eliminate customer
complaints. In fact, Southwest only receives
about ½ a complaint for every 100,000 customers
they serve which is by far the lowest in the
airline industry. Gary also doesn’t nickel
and dime his employees either. Right before
the pandemic started, Southwest dispersed
$667 million worth of profits to employees
which came out to roughly 12.2% of each employee’s
salary. 10% went towards their retirement
plans and the remaining 2.2% was dispersed
as cash. At the end of the day, the secrets
behind Gary’s crazy employee and customer
satisfaction rates aren’t actually all that
crazy. All he does is give his employees and
customers the freedom to make their own decisions,
treats everyone as equals, and he doesn’t
nickel and dime anyone. You would think that
these principles are pretty easy to apply,
but given how many douchebag CEOs there are,
this clearly isn’t the case. But hey, at
least we have a couple of star performers
like Gary. What do you guys think is the biggest
key to Gary’s popularity amongst employees?
Comment that down below. Also, drop a like
if you think all CEOs should learn a thing
or two from Gary. And of course consider joining
our discord community to suggest future video
ideas and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered.